alors
bonjour, je suis le profond et même si j'ai le
privilège d'être l'un des plus
grands super-héros du monde, je suis encore plus
privilégié aujourd'hui d'annoncer mon nouveau
titre en tant qu'associé en chef de la durabilité
chez Liquid Death Mountain Water
Scientists la plupart des dauphins que je '  J'ai
parlé pour dire que d'ici 2050, la
pollution plastique l'emportera sur la vie des poissons livre
pour livre dans nos océans et c'est pourquoi
la mort liquide est de l'eau de montagne pure
vient dans des canettes en aluminium parce qu'elles sont
recyclables à l'infini
[Musique]
dix pour cent de tous les bénéfices vont à aider l'
océan  nettoyer le plastique
c'est plutôt cool
[Musique]
nous pouvons tous être des héros en déclarant la mort
à
[Musique] le
plastique ça brûle quand je respire c'est
rafraîchissant de faire le bien alors s'il
vous plaît gardez nos océans beaux
[Musique]
vous